vous nous demandez aujourd'hui de
débattre d'un texte actan de force une
relance une nucléaire alors que la
filière va extrêmement mal les piscines
de déchets débordent les opérateurs du
nucléaire sont fragilisés par des
déboires industriels en cascade en
France comme à l'étranger nos centrales
vieillissent mal pour preuve la moitié
du parc était à l'arrêt cet été et de
nouvelles fissures ont été retrouvées
sur deux réacteurs d'une ampleur
inégalée
[Musique]
on nous demande de voter sans aucune
étude d'impact une mesure qui peut avoir
des conséquences sur la sûreté nucléaire
de notre pays on nous demande de voter à
l'inverse des conclusions de tous les
travaux parlementaires qui ont été faits
depuis 10 ans ça vous étonne pas quand
même que le président et la rapporteur
d'une commission d'enquête sur la sûreté
nucléaire qui sont membres de la
majorité et qui sont plutôt considérés
comme des gens modérés vous disent que
c'est une folie de nous balancer ça
comme ça à l'inverse de tous les travaux
que nous avons fait quel est le respect
du travail du Parlement dans ça enfin je
suis choqué de ça et je ne laisserai
personne laissez croire qu'il y a un
changement d'une ligne de nos procédures
de sûreté nucléaires car c'est ça le
point essentiel notre sujet c'est d'être
plus fort sur la sûreté nucléaire au
fond
l'autorité administrative indépendante
sort renforcer face au pouvoir politique
[Musique]
la fusion si je la comparais de manière
un peu triviale c'est un mariage nous
sommes opposés à ce mariage et que
Monsieur miel nous propose d'être témoin
ce que nous refusons allègrement en la
matière
la maman est adoptée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]